today we're going to do something
completely different we're going to be
basing our lecture over a player and we
are going to have a player that is very
famous in chess history for his
aggressive and wonderfully tactical
style we're going to be talking about
latvian grandmaster alexei sheer off now
Sherriff's a very interesting player
does anybody know anything about Alexei
shear off he was known as a double dutch
player here's one of known as one of the
most interesting and tactically diverse
people you know he wasn't afraid of
gambits he came up with a lot of
interesting ideas in the opening that
were always double-edged always very
attacking he took many risks now he was
at one point a very strong player he
defeated Kramnik to a challenge Gary
Casper for the world championship title
back in 2000 now as you can remember in
that match it ended up being Kramnik
beating Kasparov you might be wondering
why he didn't just say Shira feed
Kramnik yes that's exactly what I said
but due to sponsorship problems
it was cramming that ended up
challenging Kasparov so that's a long
political history and sheer off is a
player that not not that much was
expected he was known as a talent but he
wasn't known as the talent he wasn't
known as Kasparov he did nobody thought
he was gonna be kramnik but he proved a
lot of people wrong he was able to climb
the ranks and he play a fantastic chess
he spent a lot of time in Spain and he
only moved back to his native Latvia a
couple of years ago where he changed
Federation's and now he plays for Latvia
still a relatively strong player but
definitely he's not the Shearer of the
dominated chess in the late 80s early
90s he is Latvian so technically he is
Soviet but he I do not believe he ever
actually lived in Russia so depends on
what your definition of Russian would be
at that point now we're going to be
looking at a couple of games including
his most famous game ever
sheriff had a particularly bad score
against one player he had a terrible
score against Gary Kasparov in all of
their years of playing chess sheriff
never ever ever beat Gary Kasparov in a
rated standard game of chess it's akin
to the carlson nakamura there's some
similarities but alright I do not want
to improve my color scheme all right
next time I will we're going to start
with sheriff's most famous games
now think about sheriff is that out of
all the players in all the history of
chess he is credited to have the most
beautiful move ever played in history so
we're going to be talking out taking a
look at that game and although we I
could just jump to that spot I want to
actually give you the background of this
game exactly what was going on in the
tournament and how they reach that
position the game is Veselin Topalov
who at the moment is number three four
in the world I believe he's number four
maybe five in the world and he's
definitely top five and back then he was
still one of the top players in the
world back in 1998 this is the Linares
tournament back when Linnaeus was one of
the hubs of chess every February and
he's playing against Alexey she'd off
who is black now this is 1998 so we're
talking about quite a few years ago but
still the impression that this game made
has been kind of marked and basically
every grandmaster that's living I will
say that I want to keep the current
color scheme
so we have this position which is
clearly not an endgame but we're going
to take a quick look at how it got there
now this is a complicated groom field
and you can tell that it's a complicated
groom filled by the pawn structure you
can see that why it's being able to set
up something on the queenside somehow
some pawns got traded this might have
been a Sicilian but outside Sicilian or
groom field I don't really see how this
could have possibly come up here top
olive placed them of age three which was
considered to be a mistake back then
after Bishop d7 a4 shear up took on a
four now we're going to skip over the
opening because well it doesn't really
matter to the lecture and we're not
going to spend too much time in the
middle game but I do want to give a
little bit of background on how Shira
even this even though he was known as
this crazy attacker had an affinity for
end games and had an affinity for
defense that was unparalleled in certain
situations so Bishop 82 was played
Bishop y8 and we're going to just move
on a little bit 596 f5 clearly at this
point sheriff's got an extra crippled
pot on the a file this bonds are really
not worth that much at least not for now
top olive has this powerful pawn Center
push in the middle this Bishop is coming
on the a to g8 diagonal which seems
pretty powerful and impressive it all
seems to be going wrong for black but
somehow shear off manages to hold this
position together without actually too
much prop too many problems 95 was a
very important move since it cuts off
the bishop on a2 and attacks the pawn on
c3 Bishop d2 is considered an exact I'm
not going to get into that and a very
important resource night before now that
I took a sip of coffee I'm sure that
everybody realized upon this pin you
cannot actually take the knight so Queen
takes a four Knight takes a two Queen
takes a two Bishop takes e5 sheriff now
it's up to Paul and sorry one pawn but
the pair of bishops the pair of bishops
we know is a very dangerous it's a very
dangerous combination of pieces in open
games poetics H takes Bishop g5
and rugby 5 now as whoever annotated
this game says two bishops and a spare
pawn for black but here I still have to
survive some dangerous obviously his
King on g8 still not feeling like the
safest piece on the board rookie three
was played and we're going to see how
sheriff takes this endgame so it takes
his game and evolves it into an endgame
a pretty nice c4 here by Topalov the
idea of c4 was really tactical he wants
to get rid of this Bishop on e5 so as to
attack the dark squares so even though
this combination cost him a pawn he
wants to be able to maybe put a bishop
on f6 a queen to h6 and you know
checkmate shear off on the dark square
somehow saying that well when you're
playing opposite colored bishop
situations it's not so important what
the material balance is it's more
important what King safety is that's all
that matters so here sheriff says well I
need a safeguard my king rook e8 first
was a very very important move the Queen
on e3 felt very comfortable had to be
moved away Queen c3 Queen takes Bishop
h6 and part of the ideas here I think
that this is actually quite deep the
position obviously favors black you have
two pawns but winning is far from
trivial there are many end games in
which you can go to that because of the
opposite colored bishops they will
simply be drawn further more positions
that are not in games tend to be very
dangerous for black when the quiz are
still alive there are too many
dark-squared weaknesses for you to make
progress on top of everything you don't
have a counter-attack white king is way
safer than yours so the problem becomes
how do I actually win this position may
be drawing shouldn't be a problem if I
could manage to exchange Queens I can't
lose the end games but winning that's
not so easy we're going to see how this
very precise play sheriff actually
manages to win this endgame rookie 5 was
first now it's very important that
tactics work for black in this position
some traits will not be beneficial for
black and some will for example if rook
e1 Bishop takes h3 is an important
resource the Queen has to guard the e1
rook so you cannot take on h3 but
because of the pin down the diagonal
also the port cannot take on h3 due to
the checkmate threat on g2 you don't
have time to take on e5 and this game is
winning for black also important if
white tries to activate the rook with b1
this simply allows me to play Bishop
takes h3 and in the case of Queen takes
h3 the move rook h5 would finish the
game
rook f3 was played in order to avoid
this kind of ideas then after Queen c5
she of kept trying to trade Queens he
wanted to say hey middle games are
dangerous let's go into the endgame I'll
take my chances maybe you can draw but
I'm sure that two pawns are still two
pawns Queen a1 was played Bishop f5
rookie 3 now this is move 40 so a little
bit of a threat right you cannot take on
e3 because Queen g7 would be checkmate
hello f6 was played rookie 5 and 25 and
we got into a very complicated endgame
and I just want to point out a little
bit about what was happening in the
minds of these two great players see
when you and I see this position okay
mainly you guys when you see this
position you just kind of assume general
concept you assume things like well I'm
up a couple pawns or my kings week or my
king can go here or my pawn can go here
the difference between these guys and us
is that they're not thinking like that
they're calculating and I cannot stress
enough how important it is to calculate
and especially calculating n names the
more simple and any game is the more
likely it is that you can turn you can
tell which result the game should end in
by sheer brute force for example all
pawn n games do have three possible
evaluations
White's winning blacks winning that's a
draw there is no slightly better
there is no clearly better there is no
decisive advantage there is winning lost
or drawn why because they are so simple
that we can calculate it out towards a
result in this kind of positions the
same is true the difference was that
sheer of out calculated to Paulo after
the move played in the game we need to
check and this is very important because
if you take only five taken five I have
three fast pawns and you can't stop all
of them with a bishop and a king you
just just can't there's too many
you can't actually pass your opponents
because opposite color bishops he did
not exchange he first played Queen e2
Chuck simply moving the Queen out of the
way and sheriff came up with a
surprising Queen d5 so here's what the
pile of thought I'll go to trade and he
did he should have by the way not traded
conceptually it's stronger not to trade
but he calculated it out and he thought
this is a draw so he takes takes and he
says Bishop d2 I attack this one a for
Bishop c3 attack this one fourth King f
7h for King e6 King g1 and now this was
the polyps idea if the move King d6
happens then you have King F to not take
only five on f6 by the way King here
King III I controlled this square I win
this spawn in the next move and the game
should end in a draw there is no way to
pass the pawns you can't do it the King
is controlling
so at this point we had kind of a
difficult situation the King cannot
really come closer because obviously d5
is taken by the pawn f5 is taken by the
bishop and E 5 is taken by oh sorry by
this bishop now I don't have the time to
play King F a key enforcer for example
if I play we should be walking if to
King f5 just King III should be able to
draw the game yes you're up to pawns but
because of the opposite color bishops
you can't make any progress the King
keeps controlling the d4 and a1 squares
which are really the only thing that you
can make progress in so she rephaim up
with what was called at the time the
move of the decade then it was called
the move of the century and considered
now it's considered to be the most the
prettiest move to have ever been played
in a real tournament game at least it's
my opinion he played what looks to be
the absolute worst move on the board
Bishop h3 this move looks stupid I mean
you're just it's the only way you
managed to almost lose this endgame but
surprisingly and what makes this so
beautiful it's also the only winning
move the the idea is simply to gain a
temple she realized it in all the
variations that we've been looking at
the bishop never played any role because
the bishops are of opposite colored it
doesn't help you push the pawns forward
therefore the bishop is being used as a
kamikaze piece in order to drag White's
King behind black absolutely needs to
control the square e for if you Lance
the King on e4 he'll be able to shoulder
out the opponent King and take control
over the incredibly important d4 square
so there are many variations here we can
take a look but the most obvious one is
if you ignore the bishop
the bishop will insist on sacrificing
itself and then we will reach a position
that was basically the same we're going
to be looking at but up what's down upon
so we're going to take a look at gtex h3
which happened in the game King f5 King
f2 Keaney for now a major point is that
if 8-3 happens I've created three paths
pawns
because of the F pawn now being passed
right a3 King the 2d for Bishop a1
obviously the bishop doesn't have any
choice but to go to a 1 here and f5 you
cannot control every pawn also you have
no counter play because even though you
have two points on the H file they
actually cannot create a passport on
their own therefore after Bishop takes
f6 in order to eliminate this important
pawn
d4 was played locking out the bishop
from the a1 square now if he need to
immediately a3 wins the bishop does not
have a route in order to defend a 1 on
time also since the pawn direct this way
clearly the king is out of the square
everybody familiar with the square right
okay so Bishop e7 was played in order to
immediately stop that pawn and you're an
important move you cannot allow the King
to come into play King d3 Bishop c5 King
c4 gaining a tempo on the bishop the
bishop retreats obviously this pawn
endgame is completely hopeless because
after takes here you can see three you
still cannot get to my pawn Bishop e7
and King b3 Topalov resign the problem
was that against pretty much any move
that happens in this position for
example King b3 Bishop c5 d3 King III or
whatever I get to this configuration
sooner or later the bishop must stop the
pawn and I simply use my remaining
passed pawn
on a 3s a kamikaze the a3 will distract
the Bishop from the pawn at some point
you might as well take it now and then
after d2 I win by queening on the next
move so the important thing is that
Bishop h3 was not only such a surprising
move but it's it's one of those moves
that's actually difficult to understand
it's been analyzed the setting has been
analyzed - to a fault and we know from a
long time that it's the only winning
move but even modern computers have a
lot of trouble finding Bishop h3 they
don't have the depth or the
understanding usually to see Bishop h3
if you can see the top suggestions by
computers Houdini was able to find it a
deaf 37 but even stockfish a deaf of 77
was unable to consider this is the
winning move and of course Fritz has no
hope computer somehow just don't think
of Bishop h3 all the other alternatives
are considered to be quite complicated
and none has been proven to actually
give a win so it's not just that it was
a impactful move from like an aesthetic
point of view it wasn't just that wow
this guy's fancy no I was it was
actually the only way to win so that's
what in my opinion makes it the best
move in history is just like wow it
looks like the worst it's the best and
it's the only so sheer off he was an
excellent calculator and obviously he
was very capable in end games I don't
think it got a look at a couple of end
games that he played in various
different styles so I'm oppositional
some are more boring someone more like
wow he won that because he had a very
precise understanding of end games so
first we're going to take a look at an
incredibly tactical game this is one of
sheriffs crown jewels in my opinion even
though it's not mentioned everywhere
here he is this is actually the same
year of the tupolev game he's black
against Amash Markovski who is a
grandmaster from poland but nothing
extremely memorable just the just a
grandmaster
and we're going to skip the opening
because who cares
it's an endgame lecture from what they
told me and we are going to get to this
point
Thomas Markovski Grand Master from
Poland and black is Alexei she'd of
whatever the revenge time memorial was
it was apparently the 35th edition and
it was in 1998 apart from that I don't
really know much more of the game so we
got this position which is kind of super
messy super super messy and I'm not
going to take the time to explain
everything that's going it's weird
this Knights attacking this Bishop this
Knight is spin to the Queen this is
hanging blocks up a pawn this is hanging
because of the pin yada-yada-yada
block seems lost somehow he's not I
don't know it's weird
this position is weird but out of all
the complications and again we're not
going to analyze all the complications
which include Knight takes f2 9 takes g3
and what was played by shear of Bishop
takes f2 he found out probably the most
precise continuation after Bishop f2
Knight takes F root x f2 Knight x f2
rookie 7 is forced because this this guy
was hanging so rookie 7 Bishop c2 route
d7 which is correct if you take on the
8th take on the 8th King takes f2 you
get a version of the game that's worse
we're going to take a look at that soon
rook takes d7 rook da exclamation mark
rook da root da night c4 and we can kind
of take stock of what's going on in the
game we got a lot of sacrifices and
traited checks and everybody took
everybody and I'm assuming they're
grandmasters and they know what they're
doing so let's see what's going on
material balance is a knight and a
bishop against the rook under normal
circumstances if you came up the meaning
game and told me I sacrificed my knight
and Bishop for a rook and two pawns I
just stopped talking to you but there
are certain special rules in which
actually the rook and upon or a rook and
two pawns tend to be better than the
minor pieces
those tend to be and there's this not
always this is not a hard rule but they
tend to be positions in which a the
minor pieces do not coordinate very well
this is quite clear in this case the
minor pieces on h4 c4 b 2 and g2 don't
seem to particularly have a clear target
at the moment they're just kind of there
they don't coordinate terribly well
second there are pawns on opposite
flanks in this case because there are
Knights they don't have a good way of
actually defending both flanks at the
same time usually Knights are very short
reached pieces they only moved a couple
of squares at a time therefore they
can't really handle this open type of
positions and lastly if the rook is able
to penetrate if the rook can harass the
enemy pawns usually the two pieces are
particularly useless at defending them
they have to choose between a role as
passive pieces or a role as active
pieces and since they are forced into
passivity for the act from the active
rook they tend to be quite bad in this
case here if I understood that his rook
and two pawns were worth more than the
two pieces something that's unusual in
chess usually it's much easier to play
with the two pieces so after night d3
Bishop a3 b-59 a five I'm going to skip
ahead a little bit
Sherriff played pretty much a fantastic
endgame now this is this to me is one of
the best combinations ever played the
move b4 looks again like pretty much the
worst move on the board because after
the move Knight takes c6 which is forced
because this Bishop was trapped this
rooks hanging and this pawn is hanging
because of the unique properties of the
night it can also controls b8 and it
controls d4
therefore you cannot defend the rook and
you cannot defend the pawn at the same
time cheer just doesn't care
he plays pawn takes a three night takes
d8 and now he is down a full-piece now
you marry mortals will be like okay of
course you take on v3 and somehow you
promote the pawn right sheriff is no
mere mortal and he doesn't say things
like oh he'll probably promote the pawn
he calculates until he makes sure he
does it and he realized that this is
actually not ideal
he thought night before was a better
move leaving the pawn on b3 alive in
order for the bishop on g2 to not be
able to catch your pot on a3 and this is
exemplified in the line of the game
Knight f3 Knight takes a 296 the
amazingly strong and this is to me every
time I look at the sign game I'm like
wow how do you even come up with this
move Bishop b4 the idea is that somehow
White's coordination is so bad that
because I'm attacking the knight on c6
you don't have a good way of defending
it because after Knight ft4 takes on c6
takes on c6 the brilliant a5
the point is that after Bishop d5 night
before take some before take some before
thanks to the existence of this pawn on
b3 it's unstoppable
a - and Queen on the next move if Knight
takes a three
sorry Knight takes a five night before
again because of the existence of the
pawn on b3 you do not have the
possibility to retreat the Knight to b3
and catch the pawn on a 1 therefore b4
was played but now it is too late I do
not take with the night which would be a
huge blunder take with the night I take
before taken before Bishop d5 suddenly
your pawns are caught no you take with
the pawn and here white resigned if you
will just try to make a move here
actually if Bishop d5 Knight c3 I'm
threatening a to winning your piece I'm
going to win a piece no matter what so
for example Knight X before Knight takes
d5 you have to retreat in order to keep
the pawn under protection yes you don't
have time to take on d5 and now we have
a passport and a3 a free pass pawn at
the Kings side eventually I'm up a pawn
I'm up two points in a knight end game
which is easily winning so instead of
you know suffering through this
Murkowski simply resigned again it's
like he had a feeling for what the
position was he thought it was really
good and then his tactical calculations
were always absolutely superb so we
looked at that now we're going to look
at a oh yeah a certain English man who
had a really nice time and seen Lewis
this past weekend that is funny because
he didn't
Nigel short was playing against alexey
shavelev an Olympiad in 1996 that's
right so we're going to skip ahead
because I don't care about this part and
we got to one of the weirdest end games
ever
yeah we're going to go forward and we're
going to yeah now we're going to go to
this end game which to me was like why
what's going on isn't this like
obviously a draw how can you make
progress with wide right the works are
completely controlling the seventh rank
the Queen sites closed equal I mean you
cannot do anything with the pawns on e4
the opponent g6 is already stopped okay
somebody come up with a plan yeah what
cheer-off
you have to come up with a plan to break
down blacks defenses that looks
impossible everything looks defended
you could push the palm but I'm going to
keep the queenside closed also I'll take
it and I'll say thank you
well they found my pawn you play g7 well
I guess it was uh it was blacksmith but
okay it doesn't matter the point is that
after g7 takes okay King e6 if it was my
move I could have played route d7 if
it's if it wasn't my move 47 check
doesn't really matter it shouldn't
matter you can soup's on me out of it
but it doesn't matter at all sheriff
came up with a pretty brilliant plan
well we're going to see the thing about
sheriff is that sometimes I don't
believe what Grand Master's are saying
because you know they kind of enhanced
their analysis a little bit but we're
gonna I'm going to steal a couple of
lines from sheriff sheriff's analysis
that he actually did for this game and
I'm going to just read you guys a couple
of paragraphs having thought for long on
mu 42 I more or less found the winning
plan if he doesn't do anything however I
was still afraid of certain tricks to me
this looks like a nonsense paragraph and
it did for some time first of all what
do you mean you found a winning plan
second what do you mean tricks what
tricks the crooks are tied and then the
more sheer off like delved into
variations and the more he like
explained through variations in his
analysis the more I realized oh my god
this guy see so much he actually thought
that there were a lot of variations
where white if you push too hard might
end up losing and we're going to see how
oh yeah and we're going to see how white
is at the brink of losing but actually
wins rook g7 and we're going to maneuver
around for a while
so okay rook g7 c4 c4 exclamation mark
here I again was confident the game was
won I was like what hmm all right
BTech c4 loses to Queen f1 now look at
what this guy saw rook h7 check this was
this guy's analysis now you cannot take
on h7 because of a known perpetual idea
you cannot cross to FDF file ever
because of rook f7 Chuck so you thought
King it activation of the rook and then
he thought Queen f5 back here King f6
rook e8 Queen d7 check King e6 Brooke h6
takes with a winning position somehow
breaching blacks defenses instead of
black keeps the Queen side closed by
playing b4 Queen f3 route d7 windy one
Ruby a queen a for rugby six so now
there is no pressure in the Kings side
the Queen has maneuvered to the Queen
side by the rook still keep it at bay
b3 King f8 a3 finally breaking the Queen
side now I can finish the game just with
hands like this was basic takes takes
rook a7 root k 7 Queen a1 exclamation
mark King J Queen f1 transferring the
Queen again to the King side after
making the break on the Queen side rook
b b7 Queen f6 rook d7 b4 takes c5 takes
25 and to me this was like what what
just happened
white sacrificed all of his pawns on the
Queen side in order to create a new file
for his Queen on e5 therefore
threatening the move not only Queen e8
check which is usually you don't in just
like we know that King f8 but also Queen
B a check
with no good way of stopping it shear of
resigned now what I want to point out is
the way the Queen maneuvered which I
thought was just genius the Queen starts
here and just just look at the Queen
nothing else
it's like it went everywhere it went
everywhere and back and went back again
about anyone it was like magic sheriff
to me was always one of like the most
intrepid players and he actually got
burned pretty badly in a couple of
occasions for trying too hard you know
at some point you have to realize that
you know the game is a draw just just
just deal with it right it's a draw
sure wasn't one of those guys if she'd
have thought there was a winning chance
then there was a winning chance and he
would milk it sometimes he got burned by
it by you know pushing too hard getting
it to complications and losing this is
one of those games where like I felt he
almost did but just through sheer
willpower and persistence he somehow won
this is the game between Alexi Shirov
and Vladimir Akopian
not a Cobian which is the player from
the US but the player from Armenia back
in 1992 so after work f8 rook f6 we
enter a kind of a weird end game here a
white sub upon as we can count with our
amazing math skills and that seems to be
the only advantage the black that white
has everything else is going wrong my
pawns are weak my kings a little further
than my opponents the bishop is clearly
more powerful than the night if anything
it seems like White's trying to hold the
draw but sure of now he wasn't much for
draws after king g6 he maneuvers his
night and maybe not everything that he
did was exact and maybe not everything
that he did was perfect but the way that
he maneuvered his night keeping that
pawn in Chuck and we're going to see
which one soon to me was amazing 96 King
f6 King due to g5 the beginning of
obvious problems for white there is a
passport that will be created on the H
file and it's not easy to see how a
knight is going to stop it sure if
somehow
has no problems context King takes King
III King G for night f 7h for Chuck king
of three knight of three first
calculation how's the pawn and game who
knows yeah why but you have an outside
passport are you fast enough so this one
you cannot do it based on generalities
because if you see I have a pawn on the
H file and there's a pond on the F file
right if I can sacrifice my pawn on H
for your pattern F what makes you think
White's winning the point is that
there's no time to do that so if you
calculate it out yes white winning King
g4 and now this looks like a draw nigh
g1 probably just loses to h3 9h to draw
to King h3 and then share plays this
move Knight d4 that's like one but it's
actually kind of clever the point is
that after h3 f3 chuck giving up the
access to g3 which looks crazy
well the point is that after King G 392
check King h4 King f2 there is actually
no good move for black h2 is met with
King takes a chi to the bishop is
trapped what to do all I have to do is
push before c5 d v c6
it looks suicidal to play this kind of
way 94 somehow it works this is kind of
sheer off it just calculates game g5 v 4
not a care in the world
let's go just didn't care it's 3 now
check now there's no perpetual
because the pawns already been advanced
to age three if I go King g4 I go night
each to check King at five b5 and then
you're like what b5 not c5 no b5
stalling his pawns because if you go c5
he was worried that after a six this
bishop would be able to control the
pawns on the light squares b5 b6 night
h2 King e5 f three King f5 a3 Keaney
five a four you notice that little
temple he lost let's go over real quick
that h2 q e5 f 3k a five not a four a
three
give me five a for Bishop h1 why did he
lose a temple so that after check here I
have two you're gaining a temple on the
bishop otherwise he could have played h2
Bishop b4 G 294 Chuck
the king is kept out of c5 King me 5 qf
2 and now honestly the endgame
probably is a draw was perfect play
still it's not obvious because white is
running King g3 9f2
but with precise calculation it's very
likely the end game is a draw
it's not like a KO via a copy and has
done anything wrong in this position but
he thought he had a draw
unfortunately he didn't takes on here
takes h2 kingi - and I guess he forgot
that here sheriff can play the move King
G to see the obvious idea of retreating
the night fails to king before and
actually black wins this position it's
not even a drop you can't even draw this
as white you just take everything and
you Queen
but King g2 King takes c4 looks winning
for a block but the pawns Queen by
themselves does anybody remember what
the point is here after pawn takes e5
King d5 v6 takes a six because in this
precise moment c6 is still under control
therefore after king d6 b6 you win
because after king c6 takes this pawn in
a six controls the b7 square so after c5
somehow black ended up losing King defy
was played c6 and now the extra passed
pawn on protected passed pawn makes it
it's an easy win and the black resigned
sheer power of persistence share was an
excellent calculator sheriff was a
player that was aggressive his attacks
were brilliant but he also had this
knack of knowing where his pieces belong
in end games he had a knack for knowing
which pieces were important and which
ones weren't
which pawns were important and which
ones weren't where do my rooks go and
where they don't he was famous and since
we're running out of time I'm just going
to show you very quickly he was famous
for beating atoms in an endgame that
looked unwinnable this is the egg and
we're going to be looking at
three against three on the Kings side
with black taking on h2 on the next move
and sure made it look easy
he understood every movement this is
before the age of computers
he knew that somehow King c5 was a
mistake this looks like a normal move
but he thought it was a mistake
rook b7 and this was the part of the
point threatening checkmate and we're
going to see that even though the king
is on c5 and remains relatively open
throughout the entire game it also gets
checkmated almost always rook a six
robot B 3 g5 h4 and we're going to see
how consistently white builds mating
threats against the king king b3 rook h
1f v takes and the winning idea was this
threatening checkmate on c2 Kinzie for
rock age for check-in c5 rook c2 here
threatening checkmate again Roque three
excellent move Roque five takes thanks
check King III check here F for rook c
b3 threading more checkmates threatening
checkmate again forcing the trade of
rooks because of Chuck made and on basic
winning endgame at the end I mean this
was a deficit be like just easily from a
3vs3 endgame he was very famous for this
he created something out of nothing very
often so it does look like a a little
overstepping my time so if you guys have
any questions you're welcome to ask me
but otherwise thank you for joining us
in a little shear off extravaganza on
some of his best end games in my opinion
that he ever played
you
you